nous sommes sur la ligne de front
ukrainienne face à donetsk aux mains des
séparatistes russe depuis 2014 ce qu'il
voit avec ses jumelles nous ne pouvons
pas le montrer c'est la pointe sud de la
tna et russes pour encercler les
défenseur ukrainien du donbass cette
ligne n'a pratiquement pas bougé depuis
et les soldats du bataillon samat
attendent la grande offensive annoncée
de pied ferme ivanovic c'est son surnom
dit qu'ils se font tirer dessus
fréquemment surtout la nuit comme sur
les villages alentours et il réplique
bien sûr on doit répondre il faut bien
se défendre
de nouvelles armes modernes viennent
d'arriver cadeau de l'allemagne
l'ukraine reconnaît maintenant qu'on lui
en fournit assez
celle là vient de suède très précises
pour les tanks et d'un mode d'emploi
facile
l'idée c'est que les chars russes fils
comme celui-ci souvenir de 2014 ce qui
se produit fréquemment
le bataillon est divisée ainsi il ya le
quartier général puis plus en avant une
série de trois compagnies elles mêmes
divisées vers l'avant en trois positions
la position est pourvu d'une
mitrailleuse andriy dit qu'elle ne sert
que pour les occasions sérieuses
ensemble les positions peuvent effectuer
des tirs croisés en attendant la grande
offensive
il y à des escarmouches chaque fois les
russes ont été repoussés pas plus tard
qui est indien drei
il est ici depuis plusieurs mois
personne ne rentre chez soi et il est
prêt à rester encore longtemps jusqu'à
la victoire
tout est relié par un réseau de
tranchées constamment amélioré notre
guide dans les tranchées série n'a
évidemment l'armée ne veut pas amener
les journalistes dans des endroits
exposés mais elle veut leur montrer que
ses soldats sont professionnels bien
équipé et surtout prêts à tout déterminé
plusieurs fois pendant l'entrevue des
coups de canon venue du côté russe pour
l'instant ici l'ukraine et sur la
défensive mais comme l'armée russe en
caisse de lourdes pertes 1 pour 10
d'irina parce que nous sommes plus
technique et rapide le bataillon
s'attend à passer à l'offensive
un jour mais il est prêt comme un autre
les moineaux afghanes y quand on va
recevoir l'ordre d'attaquer dit elle
nous sommes prêts
ce que le bataillon défense sont des
villes comme cram à tort sq dans la
poche qui va de uffie foner ados n'y est
qu'au sud la gare de crest motors qui a
été touchée par un missile russe qui est
tombé au milieu de la place et dont les
éclats ont fait une cinquantaine de
morts et beaucoup de blessés sur le
stationnement sur le quai on ya laissé
des fleurs
les habitants sont partis en masse
cramatte or ce qui est une ville fantôme
presque tout est fermé ce qui reste
continuent à vaquer à leurs occupations
des transports en commun fonctionnent
non loin habarcq moutain missile a
détruit ce qui semble être une usine
probablement un entrepôt militaire
là aussi les gens ont fui la ville mais
pas ses chauffeurs de taxi il reste
on n'a pas d'argent pour partir de toute
façon mais ont-ils peur
non ils ont des sous sols bien aménagé
le sol commerces encore ouverts ici
c'est la fleuriste même si les gens sont
partis elle voit encore des fleurs il
reste des anniversaires à fêter mais
elle a peur
elle ne sait pas si elle va rester ou
partir
ces employés municipaux continuent le
travail comme si de rien n'était
plus au nord c'est sauvian sq hélas la
ligne de front n'est pas loin
sur la place entre à la sirène hurle
jour et nuit comme pour faire partir
ceux qui résistent comme les pigeons
à la limite de la ville on entend les
canons russe
[Musique]
puis la réplique ukrainienne
le canon qui attiré 120 à toute vitesse
placé ailleurs avant d'avoir été
détectées et frappé
sauvian ce également est pratiquement
désertes comme celle de cramât torse que
la gare est fermée comment évaluer les
chances de subir le sort de marioupol
ouïr pin ou bien d'être épargnés comme
kiev souvient ce qu est la première
ville du nord du de base que les russes
doivent capturer s'ils veulent faire la
jonction avec leurs troupes venues du
sud il pourrait ainsi s'emparer du temps
basse au complet tout en encerclant les
forces chrétiennes qui sont retranchés
depuis 2014 mais c'est loin d'être
acquis car les ukrainiens se croit
capable de les en empêcher et de leur
infliger une défaite pour la deuxième
fois jean michel leprince radio canada
sofiane sq